today we'll hear from antoine castex
enterprise architect at the cosmetics
company l'oreal
they built a serverless multi-cloud data
warehouse based on google cloud welcome
to the show antoine
thanks martin for having me
did you know that i have been using
google cloud since 2011 starting with
app engine
wow that that's about the same time i
started with app engine uh all right so
why did l'oreal need a new data
warehouse onto one because we have data
in many different databases in many
different systems like any large company
we need to democratize this data and
make it available to thousands of
employees
sounds great i can't wait to hear how
you did it
[Music]
alright first on to one could you tell
me about l'oreal's business and your
data needs yeah sure l'oreal had sales
of 32 billion euros in 2021 we are
present in more than 150 countries we
have many brands adapted to local
requirements and we keep rolling out new
ones wow cosmetics and personal care are
big business i guess
yes they are we need to have a good
understanding of all the data we need
for all our brands and manage
requirements for different countries we
have many brands many organizations
within the company and many retail
stores and of course many systems
so what systems do you use for that our
systems are have grown organically over
the time we collect data from point of
sale systems salesforce sap
microsoft facebook google ads
and so on
you're a large company and any large
companies has a lot of systems and data
sources right
yes that's right but our employee needs
a single view of the data from all of
the system in one place to make business
decision
we need to unify all the different
systems and see data in only one place
that makes sense
how did you manage the complexity of
that
well we decided early on that the data
warehouse will be no ops it must be
sustainable and we will use e l d
instead of the traditional etl
okay let's talk about each one of those
for a minute so first off you said no
ops what do you mean by no ops
oh i mean the job of a developer at
loyal is not to manage servers we need
infrastructure that scale on demand so
that our developer can deliver business
value instead of managing server that
makes sense how did you accomplish that
we decided to put the data in bigquery
with scales up and down automatically
i'm sure google is using servers to do
that but we don't have to deal with them
to load and transform the data we pick
it up cloud function and cloudon which
are also servers
got it
next you said your data warehouse needs
to be environmentally sustainable
yes of course this is very very
important to us and to our customer we
need to know what the carbon footprint
is for our data warehouse and we were
happy to see that google clouds include
a cable footprint dashboard because it
helped tell us about the footprint but
also how to reduce it
great i love that carbon footprint
dashboard as well i use that for all my
side projects so the third point you
mentioned is elt now i know of etl and
that means extract transform load if i
remember correctly and it's a way to
pull data from systems and to make it
useful for decision makers but what is e
lt
you're right martin etl is the
traditional approach and i used that in
my previous job and it was working well
but now
more than data warehouse like bigquery
can transform loaded data so eld is
faster and cheaper than etl
oh uh how much faster and cheaper
well we used to spend thousands of euro
on data transformation that took hour
by doing elt with bigquery we spend tens
of euro and it takes only minutes
wow from thousands of euros to tens of
euros i like that i might have to look
into elt for for next system i'm
building
okay so what was the architecture of
this data warehouse
the job of a data warehouse is to
connect data sources with data consumer
okay and before we continue what's an
example of a data consumer at loyal
that's a great question it could be a
marketing team who needs to know how
many bottles of ifs and perfume were
sold in europe versus in asia versus in
latin america
i see and how many data consumers like
that are there within l'oreal
right now we have onboarded about five
thousand users but the goal at the end
is to have thirty thousand data consumer
which represents thirty percent of the
company we need to democratize this data
so everyone can make smarter
decisions wow that's a lot of people 30
000 data consumers all right so sorry
for the interruption about data
consumers uh please continue but the
architecture and one yeah no problem the
consumer needs the data presented in a
visual way we will dashboard in looker
for that
looker okay got it and looker pulls the
data from bigquery and we like bigquery
because it's a serverless database that
means no ops like i mentioned before and
also it means that we can adopt a sql
standard as a universal data language or
analyst already nosql
very nice and now using bigquery how
does that data get into bigquery
there is two way
either the data source called an api
based on rpg
or they upload data file directly to
google cloud storage
makes sense
once we have received the data with an
api call or an uploaded file we use
cladren to do some basic cleaning and
formatting operation
okay so is that where the data
transformations happen like swapping out
country names for country codes and so
on
no no no it's not we are using elt so
the data first need to be loaded into
bigquery as soon as possible
and when that is done we can start
transforming it
oh right you're using elt not etl
you load the data first and then you
transform it
that's right now some data set requires
up to
10 transformation
it's important do steps happen in the
right order so to do that we have
defined processes in cloud workflows
oh okay uh how does that work
it is pretty simple we write up the
process steps in a eml file each steps
is a call to bigquery api with some sql
query attached to it
oh so you don't have to write code in
java or some other programming language
to do those transformations
right
it's all declarative with uml files and
sql
that means less work for our data
engineer to create the transformations
i like that less code means fewer bugs
uh now how are these cloud workflows
triggered
the workflows are triggered by an event
arc event every time a cloudron service
runs an event is generated automatically
by google we don't have to create an
event ourself we just need to consume
events
it is like magic
i love it when it's like magic
how many of these workflows do you have
we have
about
eight thousand and five hundred
different flows of data in the data
warehouse and there is one workflow for
each one
wow that's a lot of workflows i can see
why you don't want to write a separate
java or python program for each one of
those
yes sure that would probably not scale
right
okay so it sounds like a big data
warehouse but one that's pretty easy to
run
what plans do you have next next is more
sequel than ever we want to replace most
of our imperative python code with
declarative sql
sql again is the universal language
within the company so the less we do in
other language the easier things we will
be false
sounds exciting thank you for joining me
today antoine and thank you everyone for
watching if you have questions for
antoine or me please write a comment
below also let me know what other
serverless topics you'd like to see on
the show
see you next time
[Music]